foreign  [Music]  I just never thought I would come back  here  you don't got love for this city  it's not the city  it's that house  I'm the only one that made it out  [Music]  I got a drop you did doing work cleaning  pools what are you doing  pools  clean them  and look if it get dark now you just you  just ride it okay yeah yeah  how do I do that  I uh what's dog  I worked for the Army Corps of Engineers  now I need him to clear me so I can go  back you got blown up over there you  want to go back  what happened she was at a car accident  on the causeway  I'm kind of on a lot of medication got a  medication like don't treat yourself in  the head kind of medication okay  I thought I'd get through the storm  [Music]  can you go back yes  should you go back it's  a question  got a pool business going  it's cut out really  no  [Music]